i also can't think of an excuse for this
as we move
up to boston where mayor michelle wu she
may remember her she was last seen sort
of awkwardly sitting there silently
while she got insulted relentlessly on
instagram live which was a great great
a great video this one
not as good she gave a speech at the um
annual boston st patrick's day breakfast
where she said this listen
over 100 days we have connected unhoused
residents at mass and cass to housing
treatment and services
we've launched three free bus lines
we've taken some big bold actions but i
won't lie
this past winter was pretty intense
trial by snow
trial by fire fighters union
i'm getting used to dealing with
problems that are expensive disruptive
and white
i'm talking about snowflakes snowflakes
i mean snowstorm snowflakes
oh hilarious she's dealing with problems
that are expensive disruptive and white
which is a joke she decided to tell by
the way at a st patrick's day event
and the excuse that's being given
on her behalf is that
apparently at this event the tradition
is that the mayor gets up there and
gives a funny speech and tells a bunch
of jokes
okay fine
so
she's telling a joke now now all of a
sudden people on the left are saying
calm down it's just a joke
now when when an actual stand-up
comedian
at a stand-up special tells jokes
that's uh that that's that's
armageddon that's in a that's the
apocalypse that's a human rights abuse
we have marches in the street and
boycotts
you know dave chappelle's an actual
stand-up comedian it's his job to tell
jokes
and he does a stand-up special where he
tells jokes
and that's a problem you can't do that
yeah we're gonna make excuses for a
politician on st patrick's day
who decides to make a joke that all of
her problems are expensive disruptive
and white
now i don't need to point this out but i
will because there's a yeah that's
pretty much the entire show is me
pointing out things i should need to
point out um
if this was
a mayor of a city
who was commemorating black history
month
by making a hilarious joke about how
most of his problems are expensive
disruptive and black
you know i don't think all the the
people that are
having such good humor about it would
would feel that way but there would be
riots in the streets
it would be considered a
catastrophe they would build i mean they
would
literally commemorate the day that it
happened
if that happened today march 22nd then a
mayor got up there and said you know all
my problems are descriptive
expensive disruptive and black
i'm not talking about black people i'm
talking about uh the pavement there's a
lot of potholes hey don't you get it
if that were to happen
and it march 22nd march 22nd would be a
day they would have we would have
anniversaries of it
next march 22nd they would talk about
the where they were when they heard that
joke and what what terrible damage it
did to them the trauma that they've
suffered i mean we would never hear the
end of it
they would build monuments to
commemorate the tragedy where people
could go and weep over the joke that was
told
and yet
what what we are supposed to get
accustomed to and many of us are
accustomed to is just that
you know it's different
mayor wu is a non-white person and she's
making jokes about white people
and so it's just different she's allowed
to do that
that's what we're supposed to accept
that i i don't i think we should not
accept it now
as i've said before
we don't want to call this a double
standard really because it's actually
it's actually not um there is there is
in fact one standard
the standard is from from the left like
we can do things that you can't do
non-white people can do things that
white that white people cannot do that's
that's the standard
but it's a twisted perverse
standard
and we should never tire of criticizing
of it
and yes we should
uh react
with anger to stuff like this we should
be outraged about it yeah
because the only other option is just to
move on from it and say okay fine you
can do that
like i know you're doing something
that a white person could never get away
with but all right you can just do it
why should we go along with that
that's the worst it's like as as white
people you're just supposed to sort of
accept that okay well you can come and
spit in my face
all right
i don't like it but uh all right
why should we accept that
no i'm not going to have you spit in my
face especially it's like st patrick's
day
to make it all the worse
so this is your way rather than talking
about how you appreciate irish culture
you're going to tell us that your your
problems are all white
you disgusting
drooling ugly
bigot you racist scumbag that should be
the response to this person
it is because it that's exactly what it
would be in the reverse but a lot a lot
more harshly we all know i mean there
would there they would i mean the person
would be the mayor would be would be
kicked out of office
probably arrested for a hate crime and
i'm not exaggerating
but you can't even you can't conceive
you can't even conceive actually fully
of what the reaction would be because it
because because it is literally
inconceivable that a politician would
ever make a joke like that about any
race of people other than white and is
that a reality that we want to accept
that there is one race of people that
the most powerful people in our society
politicians who are running cities and
running the country are allowed to joke
about an insult do we really want to
accept that because that doesn't go
anywhere good
when there's one group of people that we
determine by race who you're allowed to
disrespect but nobody else
now you want to open up the floodgates
and say that yeah jokes or jokes you
make jokes about any race you want
and uh hey you know that's fine
if that's the rule i'm totally on board
for that
but i'm not on board for the rule that
you're that you're allowed to to do this
to white people but nobody else not on
board for that
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends